i'm a city boy i'm from new york i've
never seen a cow or anything like that
but hanging out with emu
it's pretty cool and probably won't have
another opportunity like that in the
rest of my life
we are at the monroe county sheriff's
office animal farm
on the grounds of the detention center
we have the capacity to have 700 inmates
in all three of our jail facilities this
is the main jail and we're the only
facility of this kind in the country
that has an exotic
zoo at a jail
it started out with just farm animals
and now i have exotic animals of all
varieties and kinkajous are from the
rainforests of central and south america
that's the bird we call the i love you
bird and he is such a camera hog
we only take in animals that have been
abandoned abused confiscated or donated
hi tucker we don't purchase any of the
animals and they're here for their life
this is a forever home for them i've
been here just for a year you know and
these guys are doing a life sentence hi
mo all right creamer now wake you up
pretty girl
today i have four inmates
every day they come down here to feed
water and clean and then to spend time
with the animals
what's going on buddy you're going to
get out pretty soon mandatory wreck
the farm is one of the jobs in this
facility that you could actually be
outside all day and number two get to
interact with a bunch of rare cool
animals like cramer here he's got the
little
curl on the top of his head that's why
we call him kramer this is eeyore he was
uh
he was saved from a slaughterhouse and
he's a lot better off
do you think working with the animals
helps the inmates with their
rehabilitation i've seen a lot of very
positive changes i've seen people that
come down here and are completely scared
of animals and by the end of their time
here many of them bring their families
back to actually show them what they
were doing when they were incarcerated
i'm so happy to be out here
when i first came here it was like not
even this big
tiny
and now look at you
you